[Music]
I really wanted to go here because like
there was definitely prepping you for
college it was a college experience and
I really wanted to know what that was
like and here you you learn the basics
and everything and it's also great for
your portfolio they actually you make a
portfolio while you're here and you're
going to need that portfolio for any
college you try to get an interview for
so it really does prepare you I think
better than anything else code for
college my favorite aspect of the
program would probably be doing the work
in styles because I haven't had too much
Shakespeare training one of the most
important things I'm learning is how to
navigate the audition water successfully
how to pick contrasting monologues and
how to successfully perform an audition
to do that confidently is very difficult
but they're helping me I've really
learned how to be one-on-one with the
faculty not think of them as teachers
but as people who are helping me be Who
I am you don't find that often that the
people that are training you actually
want you to succeed I have the potential
and I think what I love about the
faculty is that they make me believe
that and they see that within me there's
really nothing that I'm learning here
that won't help me later so there's
definitely a lot of things you can learn
from other people and their backgrounds
one boys from st. Tom is a girl is from
Turkey and there's people from all over
the United States which is amazing we're
different but we're still the same and
it's really great to see that and just
get to know each other one thing that I
really love about being here it's being
surrounded by people who share the same
passion as you it's an amazing feeling
and I know that I'll hold on to these
friendships for a lifetime this program
means so much to me and I didn't know
what to expect coming here and I've
gotten more than I thought I could ever
get and I've learned so much even within
three weeks you know just imagine what
you can learn in six weeks or in four
years
you